danke sagen du sagst 3 2 1 und in sagen
wir die begriffe du weißt dass du es
geht um die schwierigkeit wäre es als
erstes hat ja aber das wusste ich denn
sonst um das was hier wirklich kommt
hallo mein name ist luca hatte mein name
ist sarah und ich bin die namen
[Musik]
hallo mein name hallo mein name ist
lokal namens st
ja wir haben sie heute wieder versammelt
denn mama hatte so lust auf noch ein
weiteres video wollte sich eigentlich
gar keinen bock aber die hat sich
freundlicherweise einige begriffe
überlegt und sarah und ich müssen
versuchen das gegenteil der begriffe zu
erraten auf die 321 frühling entgegen
ich habe ja gesagt
also haben und das war auch ich oder
drei man ein bisschen langsamer 1 engel
teufel 321 20 zivis dass man muss aber
recht schnell sein die haben ganz kurz
wir haben wieder eine zweite camp und
ich werde dieses mal auch häufiger
darauf hin zu wünschen weil das mach ich
das nicht gemacht
nichts
321 klein groß war
ich glaube auch steht 3 zu 2 oder 3 2
133 finde ich jetzt ist
321 dick dünn so ich meinte ich habe das
gegenteil von dix und spotify die uns
lästig und du richtig geld so richtig um
früher bloß kein streit bei 21 nüchtern
besuchen
ich musste was hast du denn gesagt kann
ich nicht hoffe die leute eigentlich
nicht nein ich wollte aber trocken ist
doch das gleiche wie bei 21 grad so
endlich den elefanten schon was sind
schon hier passen freche begriffe kamera
321 hell dunkel
ich habe hält verstanden und hatte so
hält antiheld nie hätte ich jetzt gesagt
bösewicht wie stets 321 freiheit
eigentlich dürfen halt gefängnis
gefängnis das hast du angefangen ja aber
es ist aber ja ich bin den punkt was im
handel
321 reich also du bist am hut für zu
einem brennpunkt ja es hat keiner
121 kranke gesund hey das noch nicht mal
bis es wieder gleichzeitig geblieben
321 hey dunkel 3
das heute doch schon ich wollte meinen
gästen jetzt was anderes ich verstehe 21
ich kam gar nicht drauf ist schon ein
bisschen lust oder bis zum aufräumen was
ging davon hält ist 321 mond sonne aber
auch durchziehen
daran gibt er ganz viel kraft 21
das war auch
als sie bei sorge das kommt hier eher an
irgendwer seite 321 alpaka sommer maus
di luca
[Musik]
ein packer spucken auch nein nein dort
nur wenn sie in gefahr und ja sie sich
angegriffen fühlen ich dachte acker
spucken gar nicht doch wenn sie sich
nicht einfach aus wenn sie gut erzogen
wurden spucken sie auch nur an drei
alpakas an die würden die menschen an
spucken nur den alpakas menschen und
spucken heißt das dass alpakas den
menschen als mitglied ihrer bande sehen
also einerseits süßes ist aber auf der
anderen seite auch heißt dass die kritik
wieso sprecht ihr denn immer zur
gleichen zeit bei 21 durchsichtig
blickdicht durchsichtig wer wirklich
anderes wurde da durchsichtig ist hier
richtig
ja und was hast du hast bestimmt sich
die wichtig ja das habe ich doch gesagt
das ist guck mal welche gerade sitzen
würde zu sein
wir müssen schon wieder tauschen 32 laut
leiter es war 3 2 1 langsam
[Musik]
da hat das wort einfach vorgemacht 321
glatt nicht glatt truppen milad
sie hat die straße trocken selbst klappt
was ist denn das gegenteil fest
stockerau gegenteil von glatt rau frau
321 lockig 321 katze maus hohn und ja
103 21
ja aber das ist doch nicht das gegenteil
das sind doch das spielt keine rolle
21 lustig und lustig traurig in tristan
lustig doch nicht das geht ja schon
traurig er ist es fröhlich oder
glücklich mama also die liste dass es
seine nummer 3 21 stark dinge die du
bist du bot stoff bei 21 langweilig
sluka reich tun sollte denen die nutzer
so okay das ist ja das hört sich jetzt
gut da das nehme ich jetzt mal was dann
niemals actionreich stehen
das ist dass es hier in den wettbewerb
anschließend verfügt ein getrunken genau
wisst dass ich auf jeden fall gefeiert
das gibt einen daumen hoch unter video
hier da schreibt uns der die gegen teile
der wörter die mama gesagt hat und in
die kommentare was ihr da gedacht hätte
wird sondern du kommst du ans mikro
möchten wir sagen einfach schwachsinn
[Musik]